you know who belongs in the villain pub
who's that the tiger came I love to see
the tiger king up in the villain pub I
think he's the ultimate villain in the
real world we don't watch from his II
the villain pub Palpatine's quarantine
hey rhyme Palpatine and the quarantine
Miley Cyrus with the virus
[Music]
sure does take a lot thinking the ways
to distribute hey it takes everything
you've got
sometimes you wanna go
[Music]
No
[Music]
don't tell me you're falling in there if
anyone knows how to be isolated for a
long period of time housing helps
[Music]
hmm don't touch your face palps yes
Lauren is taking longer than I had
foreseen yes I'm bored there actually to
find new ways to motivate motivate yes
to keep your spirits up and your mind
entertained just take those towns that I
wrong for saying I don't need them I
just killing myself now my stalkers dead
just like da smile did you see the
people at the beach I had a lot to know
I like candlelight and I have been doing
a lot of push-ups lately to place
to use the bathroom Thank You Paula 200
there has been a shortage of toilet
paper all right
millions keep buying out stores in fear
that they will be stuck at home without
any during a lockdown
well howdy for day I actually need
toilet paper right now what am I
supposed to do use the false but wait I
live again
I think I need some fish is an attention
[Music]
if only they were here right now
[Music]
teenagers you think that's bad
I'm a military leader and I got whooped
by an inexperienced noob
my brother is lab I saw this ha ha ha I
changed my face all the time
ha ha ha I think I'm so much better than
everyone you know what I think
I think that music has died so I can
continue to sit around kind of somebody
pleasure
oh yes never I don't think I can take
any more of this it is challenging sir
and there are many others who have it
far worse but in order to win you have
to fight the urge to give up everyone do
their part so we cannot just thing out
[Music]
yes thank you hey guys thanks so much
for watching we hope we made you laugh
in this unfunny time shelter-in-place is
serious and certainly has changed how we
are running this channel it's affecting
everyone which is why we wanted to be a
part of the stay home save lives
campaign please be safe please stay home
and let's fight this Cove in 19 beast
together there's a lot of need right now
so if you want to help please consider
donating the organizations that are
helping take action we are choosing
feeding America or because they partner
with 200 food banks nation well people
stay fit so if you're able to donate
click the button and give what you can
well alright that's all for now stay
home stay safe wash your hands because
we want to see you next time awesome
nice poor palps stay home John ah well
Skype you in Skype you in honey I just
had some conversations yesterday with
your family yep
they want you to Skype in not come here
they do even though I'm extra safe Hyup
I just touch my scratch my face just now
yeah weird it is scary I love just yeah
watching palps go stir-crazy because no
matter how evil you are when you cut
down to the isolation and boredom of
being truly alone yeah I feel like yeah
we're truly on that same boat there
yeah I'm sorry go a little bit crazy
just a little bit you go home and you
come here your kids are going to hike
you pervert I'm seeing you on your
Instagram going on nature walk I Drive
to places where people aren't and then I
photograph the Sun whatever John but
serves of this sketch I thought it was
real
touching quite endearing taking the bit
of like the the Palpatine villain pub
world and then going what would it be
like if Palpatine was in this quarantine
situation yeah my first thought is I
think we're gonna handle it as Palpatine
we all know he knows how to live
underground for a long period of time
incomplete yeah you could just clone
people have to worry about getting the
virus the joke says you know we're
hearing the same kind of jokes all the
time with the quarantine situation the
toilet paper but I thought they did
something pretty fresh with this one
even the joke with the toilet paper than
having to use the Force to clean him out
like using your imagination of what that
must look like I just imagine you know
when Rey is like having the rocks float
that's kind of what I'm imagining
happening with but yeah like it's in
space or something if you're out of
toilet paper you can also like use the
bathroom then hop in the shower
afterwards you know I think bidet
bottles are going to spike in their
popularity because you can get one right
now and just kind of insert it into your
toilet squeeze it a few times clean
yourself
there you go see I've missed plenty of
ways around this people who break bones
have to use them anyways so it's a good
alternative weirdly I thought this was
one of their best villain pubs even
though it was just Palpatine pretty much
for 95% of it maybe because this feels
connected to real life and yeah though
it's personal and there's like an actual
heart and endearing quality towards the
end of it this is actually rather
touching in a weird way yeah built-in
point of relation and sympathy and yeah
watching him entertain himself and just
the little things that he does I thought
were really well pitched like watching
him play with all the little cutout
versions of his friends was both really
funny also yeah pretty touching as well
because you know everyone gets lonely
and I loved watching also like
straighten up or not straight up like
the pictures and everything I miss going
out no hadou I mean I'm here all day
every day before this whole situation so
having the opportunity to like get out
of the home see some friends on the
weekend telling you FaceTime with people
and skyping just doesn't cut it just
need to get the hell out of here and say
yeah
I've found parks that are very much
isolated that I can go and go running in
I do have a face mask hairy hand
sanitizers around me everywhere I go
baby wiping the hell out of everything
we are wiping down everything in here
constantly no symptoms I feel great
you're not gonna catch anything from
this video anything it's John home
worried about he comes in here showing
it feels sweaty and smelly all the time
right man dirty I go hug all the
homeless before I get here that's
actually that's a real problem in Los
Angeles as well
well guys I subscribe to how it should
have ended subscribe for the real
rejects click that notification bell and
also I wanted to thank everyone over at
our patreon page I know at a time like
this where everything can be rather
scary I really want to give a special
thank you to everyone who has stayed
pledge to our patreon page actually
bigger than ever before so thank you
guys so much wanted to shout out the
people who are pledge for a deleted
tasting behind-the-scenes tear and they
also get name call out so I want to call
out some people gonna do this on our
best palpatine voice James no briga Josh
Rosa para Philip J Smith jr. Brianna
Davidson shifting car lane madness
Natalie Doran Everett big
Ryan BT doth Oh hum yeah go man we asked
if they wanted to leave the patreon page
and they said No
[Music]
thank you guys